an awful lot more you know it's uh  wow  and then  that rook takes these six comes hits the  board i mean what does it say  what's that kind of thought what was it  for it's probably not but it it's uh  well actually i was just i was just  looking at this and actually  i mean massive developments over the  last few moves let me let me just go go  through this very quickly so e6 is such  a committal moves it's the kind of move  that's either very good or very bad  because it opens up this diagonal and  after bishop d6 so you know i was  looking at knight e5 but then suddenly  this starts to get really critical  because  black has moves like potentially g5  coming up no  yeah and then g6 after maybe exactly and  and  suddenly  did this this would be six here all the  time  yeah okay i mean i'm not quite sure how  to do it maybe we throw in g5 first yeah